spacex booster landings are awesome to
watch
during landings we're able to witness a
massive cylinder gracefully land
on an extremely precise landing site
over the years
you may have noticed that spacex often
lands with boosters on a drone ship
in the middle of the atlantic ocean
while this makes the entire process look
even cooler
why in the world would they actually do
this
[Music]
well starting off landing in the middle
of the ocean is no doubt
inconvenient after all you have to log
back a massive booster hundreds of miles
just to get it back to the coast if
spacex simply landed all of their
boosters back at the launch site like
they sometimes do
i bet they could save millions every
year on transport costs
moreover the ocean surface isn't nearly
as stable
as land thus making it much more likely
that the booster will encounter problems
during landing despite all of this
though
spacex continues to land their boosters
in the ocean
now safety concerns for people down
below does play a role in this decision
but the choice actually has less to do
with cost convenience and safety
and more to do with physics here's the
thing
getting a payload into orbit has little
to do with upward velocity
the key to achieving orbit is actually
horizontal velocity
the boundary for space which is marked
by the karman line is only 100
kilometers in altitude
so there is really no reason for a
falcon 9 to be traveling at over 30 000
kilometers per hour
if reaching 100 kilometers in altitude
was all that was necessary
the high speed is there to ensure that
the rocket ship actually stays
in space a popular misconception is that
there is no gravity
once you reach space and that this is
the reason that
astronauts experience weightlessness but
this is completely false
just think about it we all know that
tides are caused by both the sun
and the moon's gravitational forces
acting on bodies of water
on earth now the sun is absolutely
massive
and you can fit roughly 1 million hertz
inside the sun
as a result the sun's gravity is 27.9
times that
of the earth so it makes sense that the
sun affects tides on the earth
but what about the moon the moon is only
a quarter of the size of the earth
and its gravitational force is only
one-sixth of the earth
on top of this the moon is 384 400
kilometers away from the earth
or 30 earths away so if the moon is able
to affect tides on the earth
you would think that earth's
gravitational force would affect a
rocket ship that's only a few hundred
kilometers
in space and it does in fact the
gravitational force of earth in low
earth orbit
is almost the same as the gravitational
force on the surface of the earth
but then why do astronauts experience
weightlessness
well this can be explained by perpetual
falling
you see astronauts aren't actually
floating in space
they're actually continuously falling at
tens of thousands of kilometers per hour
imagine skydiving from an airplane for
instance if there was no atmosphere you
wouldn't feel the air molecules
colliding with your body
at high speeds in other words there
would be no drag force
in such a scenario skydiving wouldn't
feel like falling
it would actually feel like floating as
we all know
there is no atmosphere in space thus
when astronauts are constantly falling
towards the earth
it feels and looks like they're floating
this brings up another concern though
if astronauts are just constantly
falling towards the surface of the earth
wouldn't they eventually reach the
surface well this is where their massive
horizontal velocity comes into play
as we just discussed once rockets cut
through the atmosphere
they travel horizontally not vertically
now think about how you would draw a big
circle around a smaller circle
you draw a line at a constant speed that
is slowly curving towards the center of
the smaller circle
at any point the direction of the
pencil's tip is parallel to the surface
of the smaller circle
however the change in direction between
any two points is directly towards the
center of the circle
this is the same principle that orbiting
rockets or satellites use
the rocket is simply traveling
horizontally at a constant speed
the gravitational force however causes
the trajectory of the rocket to bend
towards the surface of the earth
and create a circle hopefully all that
made sense
but what does all of this even have to
do with landing in the ocean well
when the booster separates from the
rocket the rocket is traveling at about
800 kilometers per hour and this is
almost fully horizontal velocity so for
the booster to return to the launch site
it would have to cancel out all the
horizontal velocity in the positive x
direction
and start traveling in the negative x
direction as we slow down and
change directions though we have a major
problem
the only reason rockets are able to
orbit the earth without falling to the
surface
is because they're traveling so fast in
the positive x direction
when you start to slow down you're going
to start losing altitude very fast
thus the rocket booster will not only
have to use its engines to change
direction
but it'll also have to work on
maintaining altitude so that it doesn't
fall
and explode considering this it's going
to take significantly more fuel for a
rocket to actually return to its launch
site
which would of course cost a lot of
money but
that's not it though this is really not
a matter of cost
you're actually facing a much larger
physics problem once again
whenever you add fuel to a rocket you
need to make the fuel tank and the
rocket itself bigger
however making the rocket bigger and
adding fuel to rocket
adds mass to the rocket as a result
you'll have to add even more fuel and
fuel capacity
to allow the rocket to carry the
original fuel you added
in the case of returning to the launch
site the math doesn't really work out
that well
in many cases you'll end up infinitely
adding more fuel and fuel capacity
to power the previous fuel and fuel
capacity you added
but wait planes are able to take off
from an airport circle for hours
and then just land at the airport again
no problem how is that possible then
well planes only travel within the
earth's atmosphere
so they're able to take advantage of air
resistance or drag
in fact if an airplane were to run out
of fuel it can fly for another 70 miles
before crashing
or hopefully landing on the surface the
drag force is slowing on the airplane
the entire time
but it is also preventing the plane from
just falling out of the sky
with rocket boosters on the other hand
they generally separate at about 70 to
80 kilometers in altitude
and at the height the atmosphere is
extremely thin
so the drag force is not going to help
the booster very much in slowing down
or maintaining altitude even after the
booster falls back to thicker
atmospheric levels though
the booster doesn't have really big
wings designed to help it glide
or anything like that as a result all
the work has to be done by the rocket
booster
itself considering this returning to the
launch site is impossible because of the
law of conservation of energy
the law of conservation of energy states
that energy can neither be created
nor destroyed however energy can be
transferred
out of a system for example when a
rocket launches
it releases a lot of heat into the
atmosphere the rocket system
loses energy as it heats its
surroundings but from a universal level
no energy was created nor destroyed the
energy simply transferred from the
rocket to the air molecules in the
atmosphere
before a rocket launches it only has
potential chemical energy
which is the fuel as their rocket gains
altitude though
the potential chemical energy is
converted to kinetic energy
gravitational potential energy and heat
kinetic energy
and gravitational potential energy are
great because these are conservative
meaning that no energy is lost from the
system heat or thermal energy however
is not conservative meaning that it can
be lost from the system
take a ball for example if you throw a
ball straight up in the air at two miles
per hour
it'll return to your hand at 2 miles per
hour as minimal energy will be
transferred
out of the system if you throw the ball
straight up at 20 000 miles per hour
though
it might catch fire as it travels
upwards and burn up in the air
in such a scenario the ball won't return
to your hand at
all no energy was created or destroyed
in this scenario
however all the kinetic energy you gave
the ball was transferred to the
atmosphere as thermal energy
as a result for the ball to return to
your hand safely minimal energy can be
converted to thermal energy
during its flight this same principle
applies to the rocket booster
but as we all know the only reason the
booster is even flying in the first
place
is because of the burning of rp1 or
whatever fuel it's using
so it's impossible to launch a rocket
without losing energy to the atmosphere
there are several equations you can use
to calculate how much kinetic energy you
have
and how much is converted to thermal
energy and all of that
i haven't done the math myself but elon
musk has said quote
so in order to get back to the launch
site you would have to have enough
fuel and oxygen to reverse out that
velocity
and and and boost back all the way to
the launch site
and you just don't have the physics of
it don't really allow
you to have that much it's not about
saving money on fuel or anything it's
just physically impossible
so i'm just going to take his word for
it at the end of the day
spacex lands her boosters in the ocean
because the booster is traveling at
thousands of kilometers per hour
horizontally
not vertically because of this and the
law of conservation of energy
it's physically impossible to return to
the launch site after launching a decent
payload
no matter how powerful or efficient the
engine is it's just not going to happen
if you really really want to land at the
launch site for some reason though
there are a couple of solutions one you
could just travel all the way around the
earth
and come back and land at the same place
this is what the space shuttle did for
decades
or you could feel the booster in space
or somewhere during its flight
lastly you can choose to launch a very
light payload which spacex does
sometimes do
as you can see though these solutions
aren't very meaningful when you're just
trying to land a booster
and that's why spacex has resorted to
landing in the middle of the ocean
did you guys realize that bringing back
a booster to the launch site was that
complicated
comment that down below also drop a like
if this video helped you understand just
a little bit more about the mechanics of
rocket science
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
you